[Musik]
bremerhaven größter umschlagplatz für
autos in europa aber nicht nur neue
wagen wenn hier verladen fernfahrer kann
jakob transportiert auch modelle die
eigentlich längst auf den schrott
gehören
ungewohnt für kkw sonst fast nur edel
karossen transportiert unseren leuten
keine 14 20 jahren autotransporter
gerade hat er firma und lkw gewechselt
noch macht ihnen die neue technik
probleme
seine erste tour ausgerechnet nach
italien
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist eng geworden nach deutschen
autobahnen seit jahren nimmt der
schwerverkehr zu keinen staus tödliche
crash fast täglich die straßen sind zum
warenlager verkommen
just in time darauf besteht die
industrie und auch der verbraucher die
fahrer sind unter stress arbeiten bis
zur erschöpfung bin dabei von vielen
verflucht sie sind die prügelknaben der
autonation jakob hat eine ganz besondere
woche vor sich das erste mal die italien
tour und spätestens am freitag muss er
in hamburg sein
dann nämlich steht seiner tochter eine
schwere operation bevor
also ich probiere den dänen donnerstag
runterzukommen gucken
wo die gemeinschaft noch abschmecken und
wenn ich dann weiter reden wäre schon
schön wenn ich danach sagen da hinkommen
und wir wissen noch mal eben mal wieder
an streiten kann ob sie den blick so gar
nicht gesagt wurde
davor aber liegen immer noch mehr als
2000 kilometer während sich kein in
richtung alpen bewegt bezieht tochter
berlin mit ihrer mutter das
krankenzimmer
voruntersuchungen stehen an sie
telefonieren viel mit alles gut aber die
operation ist donnerstag oder freitag ja
du musst hier sind muss man muss mal
gucken wer direkt zum krankenhaus
gekommen
aber das ist wichtig dass du hier bist
der weg muss sehen ich will probieren
donnerstag schon zu kommen aber da muss
ich sehen wie das alles läuft aber da
musst du dich anstrengend für mich unter
druck
er will seine tochter nicht enttäuschen
aber er weiß es wird schwierig
unbekannte strecke ungewohnter lkw
die lenkzeit für heute ist abgelaufen er
muss her pause machen
zeit für grübeleien der operation es
nicht ungefährlich ein schwerer eingriff
die realschülerin ist körperbehindert
von den bürgern ihre beine kaum
belastbar
beim letzten gespräch ist dass die beine
gebrochen werden sollen und gerade
gestellt werden und von daher kann das
eine ganze menge das war jetzt auch die
hoffnung machende der öfter ist auf alle
fälle das wäre auch quatsch spenden über
diese woche werde ich so dass alles
beschäftigt ihn nun schon seit wochen
es wird in kraft markt rechtzeitig da zu
sein wäre ich altmüller fährt termin
fracht
machen wir nochmal kurze kontrollgang
und auf den parkplätzen muss er täglich
mit diesen rechten auf schnitte mir auch
ich war letzte woche passiert es ist
schon ein quadratmeter was sie geöffnet
wir haben fast keinen aufreger der einen
schnitt und diesel haben sie ihm auch
schon geklaut
sie brechen das ding auf nun zins
rausnehmen
aber wir haben sie einmal 600 liter
geklaut aber und zu muss merkt man nicht
selbst wenn es mit kriegen würde würde
ich nachts nicht allein heraus gehe ich
weiß gar nicht was mich erwartet
die zur tür raus drei oder vier messer
vor mir und dann mal weg
direkt neben ihm auf dem rastplatz hat
das heute nacht gebrannt geht nicht gut
aus
muss irgendwie vom motor hergekommen
seien die sowie die das aussieht
gefährlich auch so einen engen parkplatz
so jetzt machst du dir mal gedanken
jetzt stehst du nachts hier am parkplatz
und neben dir brennt ein auto der hat
gleich gefahr gut drauf oder ich hab
gefahr gut drauf und wenn er jetzt hier
in schwarz auf dem parkplatz alles steht
und dann ist die katastrophe
vorprogrammiert wenn der eine nachts
anfängt zu brennen
freie fahrt für freie bürger das gilt
fast nirgendwo in deutschland schon gar
nicht auf der a3 zwischen würzburg und
nürnberg nach wenigen kilometern gerät
erich und den ersten stau
die a 3 hat er denn heute ist es genau
so in der richtung würzburg einmal
zwischen wiesentheid und kreuz
biebelried zehn kilometer stau schon
nach dem lkw unfall von heute morgen
zwei stunden später passiert erich den
unfall laut
schwierig befürchtet das schlimmste
die fahrerhäuser wie die haben einen
punkt wo sie abreißen und die reisen
dann beim bestimmte aufprall reisen die
ab und schieben sich nach innen
sie können sich aber auch nötig nach
china wie wie die rückwand ist und du
hast vielleicht noch eine chance aber
wenn das alles hier verein kommt es
richtig das lenkrad man bauch wie weiter
weg ist vom lenkrad wenn wir sitzen nun
halben meter rein kommen da die farbe
schwer nacht kapitän
er macht fast alles selber die leuchtet
doch nicht zu ddr zeiten hat der
autoschlosser gelernt der ist auf alles
vorbereitet die polizei hat ihn gestoppt
für werkstattservice keine zeit selber
machen geht schneller
frühere mann der werkstatt gefahren da
war nicht nur anders aus so mehr zeit
war ein bisschen entspannter und also
mir früher heutzutage machst du das
nicht mehr passiert an ort und stelle
aber da fragt sich mein chef hoch
wir verteidigen die man eine stelle der
schlosser liste wird fertig machen kann
mache koreaner wurden mach ich wenn ich
das gefühl habe dass sich ausgenutzt
werde
dann las ich dann mal schnell sein so
oder so ist schneller und billiger für
den chef hd ist ein schnäppchen
[Musik]
so
leuchtet wieder cook papier sehen dass
ich hier so wie in die luft trainer habe
er bedrückt janz schön der reifendruck
meisten noch mal welches sehen
normalerweise müssten 95 fahren tata
7,85 bar geht gar nicht so wenig aber
für den jetzt anfange kurz vor der
polizeibegleitung jetzt zur reifen zu
wechseln dann kommt der ganze zeitplan
durcheinander
er hat ja noch 47 andere kommt später
[Musik]
erich ist schon im rhein-main-gebiet
vorbei am frankfurter flughafen
er versucht immer vor der rushhour durch
dieses nadelöhr zu kommen
dafür muss er früher aus besteht wie den
hühner auf und geht auch mit ihnen ins
bett
nachmittags schon fünf endet seine
lenkzeit jetzt kommt die weiche stunde
wie er sein
da denkt er immer ein zuhause an seine
frau und sein rentnerdasein wenn ich
jetzt zu hause
dann werde ich wieder genervt warum ich
so oft zuviel frage und dann versuche
ich dann etwas im haushalt zu machen und
das ist mit sicherheit falsch was ich
mache das was ich mache ja nie was
richtig also im moment ist es wirklich
besser wenn ich netzwerkes bin ich muss
wirklich das geregelte leben ein
er sieht es zu sonderlich wie das klingt
aber ich musste ich lernen
ab morgen kann er ich wieder üben da
kommt er für eine woche nach hause
[Musik]
also wir können jetzt losfahren
baumgärtel und du fangen wir jetzt los
wenn hannah pick sagte fokko bescheid
[Applaus]
hdi ist der chef des konvois aus drei
schwerlast transporter geladen dürfen
diese riesen nur nachts auf die autobahn
die fahrer eine eingeschworene truppe ja
aber freunde arbeitskollegen gruppe sind
aber nicht unbedingt meine freunde oder
freundschaft
definiere ganz anderen freundschaft ist
die immer für mich da sind alles für
mich tun
und eckte trost selber wieder
zurückgeben konnte das für mich freut
aber solche freundschaften pflegen
unmöglich diesen arbeitszeiten
mein freundeskreis beläuft sich auf 0
freunde 0
eine bittere erkenntnis mitten in der
nacht
keine zeit für melancholie
jetzt ist konzentration gefragt sie muss
aufpassen mit seinem überbreiten gefährt
auf den engen schlecht befestigten
straßen im kreisverkehr muss ein
begleiter nach lenken
das macht er mit einer schwächeren
fernsteuerung aus einem fahrzeug heraus
der bilderdienst träumt derweil etwas im
wege steht dunkle grelle lichtblitze der
waren lampen und scheinwerfer nicht gut
für hgs chronische kopfschmerzen
er wird wieder tabletten schlucken
jetzt müssen sie sich gut abstimmen
sonst bleibt der schnell hängen oder
rutscht ab in den graben
das war knapp aber noch mal gut gegangen
sie sind sicher angekommen morgens um
drei irgendwo in der süddeutschen pampa
maximum aus der welt sondern die leute
nicht hören jetzt erst mal ein bett
trinkt noch mit robotern gehen also wenn
wir leider noch ein bisschen abschluss
muss sein schönstes wetter traum ein
hammer
bei der auto transport fahrer hat dafür
gerade keine augen
er hat es eilig will spätestens am
freitag in hamburg in der klinik seine
tochter wird operiert
1500 kilometer liegen noch vor ihm
er kennt die strecke liegt bittet einen
kollegen telefonisch um hilfe bei der
präzisen zielführung kann da die
ladestelle gar nicht verfehlen
er liegt hinter seinem zeitplan jetzt
nur schnell die autos abgeben
dann kann endlich auf holen hofft er
aber es kommt anders
bürokratie halt
ok
ok also ok stunde warten bis die
genehmigung haben das verbleiben können
und dann haben wir wieder für
deutschland aber sind drei autos bei der
müssen wir uns um zu gucken wieder
arbeitet und bis wann und ob überhaupt
noch da hinkommen heute da wird nicht
gerechnet
überhaupt nicht sehen wenn ich morgen
fahrzeuge haben sonst aber es nach hause
kommen eine baustelle mitten im wald
vier stunden hat hardy hier geschlafen
jetzt schon heraus das maschinenhaus auf
seinem schwerlaster muss als erstes
abgeladen hängen kollege thomas knopf
vorsichtig
wir schlafen stehen ruhig die sonne
planen wie saurier spiegels dreckig
alles ist dreckig
beim rest der welt die es noch betäubt
von der viel zu kurzen die kräne sind
zwar ausgebaut aber noch fehlen die
techniker die helfer sich er hätte noch
zwei stunden länger schlafen können
alles verzögert sich
es hat etwas von einem pfadfinder
ausflug aber tag romantik
[Musik]
das ernst ganz normalen arbeitsleben das
ist eben halt durch das unter straße zu
arbeiten und zu leben weil du hat man
nicht man hat keine freunde man hat
kenne man keine lobby hat man nicht gibt
keine verpackung man denkt so dippel
schnell noch was
bevor es losgehen thomas andy schleck
fährt jetzt kaffee
was jetzt so beschaulich wird wird sie
später reichen
viele maschinen aber zu wenige helfer
sind auf der baustelle
sie kommen zu langsam voran mit einem hd
müsste eigentlich längst weg sein
in einem leeren aufleger darf nur bis 15
uhr auf der autobahn fahren durch person
bis in die zeit weil die rohre möchte
lange gedauert haben weil die nicht die
komplette mannschaft war zum entlang
normalerweise tummeln wie in wien haufen
ja wenn die leute alle da sind kenntlich
seiner ladung hängt am kran hardy kann
seine rückfahrt vorbereiten
er wird hektisch
sanaa
und nicht einzeln wurden er will nur
noch nach hause zu meiner familie
so recht mehr brächte schulzimmer
stress tötet einfach zu spät hier weg
und dann hast du alles wäre jetzt auf
der autobahn hat ist aber wir erstaunt
[Musik]
wäre ich ist gut angekommen zu hause in
der pfalz gemeinsam mit seiner frau
erika fährt er einkaufen
das ist die andere seite des teilzeit
enders das geregelte leben noch
es ist nicht einfach für beide nicht
nach 43 jahren fernbeziehung erich hast
das einkaufen aber seiner frau zuliebe
zeigte sich wenig sie hat es auf der
lunge kann nichts schweres tragen
[Musik]
erika schon team nicht sie ist seine
büste fahrerinnen 1 erich an schon was
ihnen zwischen den regalen erwartet
[Musik]
naja das abgelaufene zeit löschen muss
stimmen so viel billiger ist kommando
was mit namen hat
aber was schnitt werkzeug interesse und
mächtig was ein machen wenn ich denn
allein schicken wird das wäre
katastrophal bringt alles
und dann greift er immer nach dem teuren
ja und ja auch mehr drin oder also guckt
doch der chronik ab 512 2016 allein in
deutschland bis er erzähle bis 17
ja ich es mit humor und risiko ich mache
nichts richtig nur kritik und forschung
nicht richtig an dem man kommt bei uns
aber kaffeekränzchen steht noch ganz am
anfang seiner ausbildung als
haushaltshelfer gewaltige umstellung ist
vom alleinherrscher und knechte hd cam
glatt über die autobahn hat den aufleger
auf dem letzten rest platz abgestellt
ein kleiner umweg für blumen von der
tanke
[Musik]
kurz vor zu hause fiel ihm das geschenk
für seine frau ein
hardy ohne anhänger aber mit 700 ps
er rast durch den brandenburger wald der
familie entgegen seiner zugmaschine ist
falsch zu hoch wie die häuser in den
kleinen dörfern an der havel und da
kommen sie schon oscar und tony seine
beiden söhne und diana seine frau
endlich angekommen
endlich zusammen nicht jedes wochenende
schaffte es zu ihnen
für die jungs ist papa der größte wenn
sie im lkw mitfahren dürfen aber auch
ehefrau diana freut sich ihren harry mal
wieder zu sehen und er hat sogar eine
überraschung
es ist für dich okay ich habe ein
bisschen
ein kleines idylle aber viel zeit zum
ausruhen bleibt den nicht im schmucken
einfamilienhäuschen in der
brandenburgischen provinz die
gartenarbeit wartet geräte müssen
repariert und die wäsche gewaschen
werden
wenig zeit für die kinder fast keine für
das eheleben man muster auch wirklich
mitziehen als frau ansonsten ist es
schwierig also man muss für viele dinge
schon auch verständnis haben und gerade
für diese männer probleme erwarte den
ärger den er von von der arbeit mit
brings und die schlechte laune in hama
rom weiter in der firma ist bringt
soziales zu hause habt wo sonst haben
wir kriegen ja manchmal klingen
abkriegen die dann manchmal zu hause
habe das total shell total blöd und
total aus aber ansonsten denke ich sind
eine gut eingespielte team ja manchmal
sagt er dann zum gemacht du brauchst
mich gar nicht ja aber wir brauchen
unseren papa schon der tony jaa
und ob nicht nur für die kinder und als
ehemann ist er wichtig auch als
hauptverdiener das häuschen ist noch
lange nicht abbezahlt so ein wochenende
vergeht wie im flug und bald heißt es
wieder zurück auf die autobahn bei hat
wenigstens schon einmal abgeladen zwei
stunden brauchte jetzt fürs auflagen die
neue technik seines lkw ist die immer
noch nicht in fleisch und blut
übergegangen
zudem sind die suvs zu breit passen
nicht überall er stöhnt unter der
italienischen sonne also alles was mit
winter zu tun hat schweden sagt man über
20 zentimeter schnee und zehn grad minus
wie du bist
der zoll hat ihn dann auch noch
abgefertigt jetzt gibt gummi richtung
hamburg dazwischen liegen aber auch
tierheim wieder viel zeit zum nachdenken
über seine tochter in der klinik immer
wieder fragte sich ob er wirklich alles
richtig macht als vater haben wir
probiert man opfer zu erziehen oder den
kindern beizubringen und vollzieht wirst
du nur komisch angeguckt und beide
denken wo bist du bist die ganze zeit
daran berufskolleg und irgendwann
erzählt vom prinzip wir haben sie recht
aber ist natürlich schon knackpunkt der
tut weh wenn man so wie ihn sich jeder
darüber nachdenkt dass man von den
erziehung der kinder und das groß werden
dass der kinder indianisch mitkriegt
dass der zuschauer haben zwei der op
doch da darleen hat verständnis für
jeden vater obwohl sie ihn jetzt gerne
hier hätte
kein gerät in ein gewitter er braucht
einen schlafplatz die lenkzeit 200 km
hinter plan
und ausgerechnet jetzt ist der rastplatz
wieder voll
es ist aussichtslos
ihm bleibt nur noch die gefährliche
einfädelspur fünf meter neben der
autobahn aber k s tat im nehmen und was
bleibt ihm auch anderes übrig
[Musik]
eine andere möglichkeit haben wir jetzt
mehr fahrzeit ist zu ende
das muss man so stehen wenn die wir
haben klappen und da jeder schon
so geht das jetzt die ganze nacht in der
klinik in hamburg wird tochter berlin
langsam nervös
ihre mutter kreis ex frau versucht sie
zu beruhigen aber darlehen will
unbedingt noch mal den papagei braucht
noch einen schlaf traum von der
tankstelle tut mir sehr leid weil ja in
normalerweise selber zur operation auch
dabei sein also nicht bei der operation
aber was sind die nachteile unseres
shops erfordert sich einmal schaffen
[Musik]